[Music]
all right so I was thinking so we last
talked podcast related in January and
man life comes at you fast I don't think
like yeah you're the three great
correctors of human population war
pestilence and famine and we certainly
have number two in abundance and scaling
rapidly so things have changed quite a
lot since Jen yeah and I was so I was
curious as someone who is a longtime fan
of the Stoics like yourself how how have
you been thinking about these sort of
ancient ideas or ancient strategies for
dealing with what is a very timeless
ancient problem well the first thing I
did was I looked into my stored
belongings because I moved from
California to Austin Texas three years
ago four years ago but the vast majority
of my stuff is still in storage and I
had been sent as a gift a bust of Seneca
that was still wrapped in bubble wrap so
I would write that down
opened it up and put it in an upstairs
room where we tend to spend my
girlfriend and I mornings so that I
would at least see it and so I think
that there are a whole lot of different
ways to attempt to answer this and I
will begin with putting it someone like
Seneca although he's a very crafty funny
character so he could spend a whole lot
of time on him specifically sure Marcus
Aurelius and so on as ideals that I on
some level strive to emulate and I think
the word ideal is important because it
is very easy to beat yourself up for not
being stoic or resilient or calm enough
which in and of itself is very unstuck
so it can turn into this spiral of
self-loathing related to not being one
could say still look enough or simply
calm enough
and so the first is to really recognize
these are ideals that I'm striving for
but that they are not a pass/fail hurdle
sure in that in that orsa in that
respect the second is I've been doing a
lot of rehearsal so premeditate oh ma
lorem rehearsing of the worst case
scenarios and combining that with the
fear setting exercise that I had to do
which is really just a written practice
of writing out the worst case scenario
is what you could do to decrease the
likelihood of them happening what you
could do to decrease the damage if they
do happen etc etc and a big part of that
for me has been deeply envisioning the
worst-case scenarios and what they would
not just look like but feel like to
observe and experience I'll give a
concrete example as is the case for many
people and is the case for me I have
seen my stock portfolio drop oh let's
call it 70% in value in certain cases
and I had a a good line of sight into
coronavirus and its growth quite early
on and began writing about it publicly
in want to say second week of February
but had been tracking it prior to that
so I was able to sell a portion of my
stock let's just call it February 2021
whichever was the closest week day
trading day and then I decided to hold
the rest no that could prove to be a
terrible terrible terrible decision
right this could be the worst financial
decision of my life could be but after
lots and lots and lots of discussion and
lots of number crunching lots of
thinking about I decided to to hold on
like the belief that and in this case
I'm referring to Eber and then I was an
early advisor to so it represents a
disproportionately high percentage of my
net worth now this video will be trapped
in the amber so people will go back and
say what a [ __ ] idiot if it turns out
poorly
but the decision-making process I felt
was reasonable I felt like it was
defensible now at the time the stock was
trading around $40 price per share and
the I was talking to this much more
experienced investor and he said if
you're going to hold this you need to
commit to yourself to hold for at least
five years and you should expect that
the stock will go down to 20 or 15
dollars now at the time it was about 40
and this seemed not necessarily
inconceivable but probably far off in
the distance yeah and he said when it
hits 20 and 15 you are going to want to
sell more than you do now and you need
to prepare for that and that's what I
did so I really mentally committed to
holding for an extended period of time I
prepared myself for $15 share little did
I know that something like two weeks
later two and a half weeks later would
actually hit $14 a share or two it and
that is the I have had many struggles
throughout this coronavirus experience
and considering the ramifications not
just for me but for my family I have
family members in the service industries
for instance for the economy for people
who are far less fortunate and I've I've
I've struggled a lot in certain areas
but the areas where I have not struggled
are the places where I have rehearsed to
the extent possible what might happen
such that has been one of the most
powerful stoic practices that I've been
using in the last certainly two months
well I've got a bunch of stuff this is
my Marcus Aurelius statue I bought this
when I was writing the obstacles the way
so this this is from from what I read
about it this this statues from 1840 so
I like looking at it and then thinking
like okay this that this literal piece
of stone survived through
cholera epidemics smallpox epidemics
polio the Spanish flu the flu of the
1950's so I like thinking about not just
like okay who are your ideals but then
also how have humans gotten through like
what sort of totems or reminders can you
have that like Oh life goes on like I'm
talking to you from my office and my
office was built in 1880 I think so like
this office
got through you know the Spanish flu the
First World War the Second World War you
know the Cold War and you know what I
mean
I think take like part of one of the
things I think the Stoics would ask us
to do is like zoom way out and sort of
be reminded that like hey as bad as it
is like history does go on there's no
guarantee you and I will be a part of
that history but like you know what I
mean like we'll either we won't yeah
yeah absolutely
I'm curious about the stock market thing
because that's something I was going to
ask you because one of the things I'm
dealing with I think the loss aversion
is a big part of it and it's hard for
people to manage what what I'm
struggling with is kicking myself so I
wasn't as early as you but you and I had
some conversations and so I took it
seriously I went and stocked up on food
I cut back on my travel I basically said
like hey I'm sort of a buy-and-hold kind
of guy and don't have the the exposure
that you do to some of those stocks but
but the thing I said is like hey this is
gonna be bad but it's not going to be
literally it's not going to be the worst
decline in market history you know I
didn't think that so I didn't do
anything and so one of the things I'm
struggling with is like regret you know
and and I'm wondering sort of what you
how you deal with some of that like gee
are you mad that you didn't sell more
like how are you dealing with decisions
you made that you can't undo but now you
have a lot of time to sit and think
about them yeah well that's the nature
of all decisions right I mean as I
understand the etymology the word to
decide a decision
like an incision it is a cutting away so
once you have cut away now that could be
some fake attributed to Mark Twain turns
Abe Lincoln type quote maybe ask a while
the fur on the internet but nonetheless
that's that's what I've I've been told
before so all of our decisions are
irreversible and yeah at least
temporarily speaking this is something
that I didn't grapple with until
reasonably far after the Cova 19 and
coronavirus came on to the main stage so
to speak when so when I was campaigning
in part for the cancellation of South by
Southwest which it brings 400,000 plus
people to who yeah Austin and it was be
a I was just attacked by almost all
sides and viewed as an alarmist as fill
in the blank I did not have trouble with
that because I felt like the data were
on my side but I was so focused and I
think rightly so on my household on my
family on my girlfriend at her family
and ensuring that everyone were prepared
that I did not I really wasn't looking
at say investment as an example so now
there are and I in so in part of the
reason I'm not beating myself up is that
I at the time at least in retrospect I
was beating myself up for a while then I
realized well do I even have the toolkit
to have taken advantage of that
effectively and by take advantage of
that one might be talking about shorting
the market in some fashion well it turns
out it's very easy to get your face
ripped off trying to short the market
and it's very very easy to lose that
game or at least those bets and so I
have I I do have friends who are career
investors who have the toolkit to take
advantage of something like this I gave
them a heads up
that yeah I gave them a preview of what
was coming early so let's call it late
January or early February and they
missed those opportunities and they are
beating themselves up because they do
have the toolkit and the experience and
yet they do take the actions whereas you
have say some people who did like Bill
Ackman at Pershing who I don't know made
two point six billion dollars from short
positions or something like that yeah
not bad and so I I feel as though my
perspective on that specifically has
been honed if I could use it too
dignified word through a lot of the
startup investing I've done in the sense
that it doesn't matter how many
opportunities you miss it matters how
many opportunities you take advantage of
sure does that make sense just like just
like if you're putting any other a book
or a podcast or fill in the blank it
doesn't matter how many people don't get
it it matters how many people get it and
and by that I mean if you are really
waiting for the fat pitches is Warren
Buffett would say not necessarily with
his style of investing but if you're if
you understand where your core
competencies are and can focus on the
most appealing opportunities you can
miss a lot of opportunities and net-net
still do very very well so I've you I
try to keep that in mind and as you said
a little bit earlier to zoom out and not
look at this as a an anomaly of a few
weeks so it could be it could be that a
year from now we look back and the
lowest low was in fact whenever it was I
can't remember one the lowest though was
March 12th or whatever it was that might
be off so but some early March or
something like that yeah to 2020 at the
same time this could be and I suspect it
will be
some level a marathon and not a sprint
so there will be more opportunities and
then the reframing of the question for
me relieves a lot of stress so instead
of asking why didn't I take advantage of
Acts what could I have done that I
didn't do those are fruitless questions
that just create a lot of stress if you
were to ask how might I look for
opportunities that do not have the time
sensitivity of trying to time the stock
market and one could say the futility of
trying to time the stock market because
even in a bear market and look I'm not a
professional public equities investor so
no one should take investment advice
from me and I'm not giving investment
advice but the even in a bear market
there are these rallies that can really
hurt you not necessarily financially
although they can but psychologically
right where you buy and then they spike
and right now the volatility meaning the
you know simplistically the the amount
of up and down is just unbelievable so
you're gonna get whipsawed no matter
what and that can be super stressful so
so I'm asking myself well rather than
look at my god awful computer screen all
day like everybody else in the world
look at all the same information and and
and develop the like hubris and
ridiculous delusion that I can somehow
parse out a unique conclusion right when
millions people are doing the same thing
what do I have access to
where are my strengths where are my
weaknesses what can I do that if this is
a marathon or if this is going to last
at least six months there are
opportunities that might be able to take
advantage of where do I have unique
domain expertise or an informational
advantage right so yeah maybe that's I'm
making this up right but maybe that is
real distress real estate in Austin
let's say since I'm here right yes
maybe that is any number of other things
but it's probably not going to be
figuring out whether Google or berkshire
hathaway is going to move one direction
or another and how much they're gonna
move that is being the sucker at the
poker table I think so yeah so that's
that's maybe a very short winded way of
saying it but my belief is there are
times when I make very fast good
decisions but I almost never make good
rushed decisions so if I feel rushed to
make a decision because oh my god it
might go up might go this my goodness
and it might do that
it the likelihood of me making a bad
decision is very high right and and the
cost of undoing that bad decision can
also be quite high so that that is to
say that if you have dry powder I mean
in cash I think I don't think it's I
don't think it's a terrible place to be
right now but again not I'm not a
registered investment advisor nor am I
giving investment advice but that's how
I'm thinking about it personally no I'm
and I think for me it's it's it's less
like opportunities that didn't take
advantage of and steps that I should
have taken to protect myself and so that
connects to another emotion I think a
lot of people are feeling that I'd be
curious you're sort of stoic take on it
give it like the South by Southwest
example is a great one so you and a
handful of other people campaign they
shut down South by Southwest early who
knows how much impact that had probably
a significant amount because it was so
early and then government officials in
Texas and all over the country basically
and this goes back to when it was first
coming out of trying to sort of sat on
that time it's not like we use that time
and built a bunch of ventilators and you
know sure so so howhow are you
processing or maybe you don't have me
but for someone who has a lot of anger
about how this went
or is feeling anger how do you suggest
sort of what do you think this don't say
about processing that anger because I I
do know that the Stokes did not tend to
see anger as a productive or healthy
emotion yeah
I'd be curious to hear your take on that
so maybe I'll turn it around I assume I
do it mic default gear for decades was
anger yeah but right now my focus is
related to my locus of control yeah in
the sense that my source fear of control
has been constrained down to the family
effectively sure and my closest friends
and ensuring to the extent possible
those people are safe and prepared and
financially capable to to cover their
assurances and so on I am more active as
you know yeah the national level as well
but I suppose I mean and this is maybe
cliched but it's I would think of the
serenity prayer and you probably have
the full text somewhere but you know in
essence the sort of strength to act on
the things that you can act upon and the
wisdom to know that which you cannot act
upon our influence and I would say also
that I I don't think that the time
bought by cancelling South by Southwest
was used optimally yeah but just in
having that time and delay there was a
huge benefit right sure wasn't used
optimally but but I am satisfied with
that outcome because it has allowed us
to see case studies like New York City
that then spur local and state
governments to do more so that they do
not become the next case study and also
in retrospect looking at for instance
Mardi Gras in New Orleans breaking that
Spring Break in Miami and Florida I
don't think those are uncorrelated to
those two locations among a handful of
others becoming the next hot spots so
I'm very confident in the the the
benefits of South by being delayed anger
let me think of
anger for a second because I am a
somewhat I'm a connoisseur well I was
what I was thinking about anger is like
okay in war you could see how anger is a
somewhat productive emotion it's sort of
a fury that you could direct at the
enemies so you might at least be able to
make the argument that that it has some
productive benefits obviously the a
pandemic doesn't care how much you hate
it cancer doesn't care what names you
call it right like so when you're
fighting something like this I think you
always want to think about like is anger
productive yes or no and then one of my
favorite Marcus Aurelius quote see it's
it's a quote we know from Europe he's
the playwright but he says why should
you feel anger at the world as if the
world would notice and so that's the
other like Trump doesn't care that
you're angry at him the governor of
Texas doesn't care that you're angry you
know like so so in and in fact if you
are active in politics or at the
national level you have to work with
these people so I think you're also
seeing some of the governor's Democrat
and Republican having to figure out oh
hey if I if I yell at this person on
television that might feel cathartic but
then the next day have to call them and
ask for ventilators or ask for the
National Guard so so I think what the
Stoics talk about is like is anger
making things better or worse and 90% of
the time it makes it worse that doesn't
mean that there wasn't something wrong
and you can't be upset about it but it's
you've got to control that anger because
there's a problem solved
yeah I agree and what I've also been
trying to do and this this actually came
out of an interview I did some time ago
with Bosma st. John who is an incredible
woman and one sort of philosophical
tenet of hers she underscore it was
applauding what you want more of not
just berating what you want less of and
I think the Internet has enabled a lot
of things including the dominance of the
noise that is just bitching and moaning
without any clear proposal for solutions
so
I have been spending the majority of my
time
reinforcing particularly politicians
yeah who are in the game everyone's
playing a game sure you you and I are
playing games and we all play games and
there are our rules there are stakes
there are rewards sometimes there are
punishments and step number one is
figuring out what game or games you are
playing and one of the games politicians
play is re-election and seizure haveyou
have to think about if you want to
persuade someone who is playing that
game or not just persuade but to
collaborate in some way or enable
someone who is playing that game you
have to think about the incentives at
play and to that and I've been trying to
support people who are making good
decisions even if they are late yeah if
they are better late than never
decisions and that's coming from someone
who I mean has had a lifetime of anger
so I I do think the certainly the stoic
philosophies and philosophers and
writing has had a tremendous impact on
my intellectual understanding of why
anger can be counterproductive but it's
really been getting on the playing field
and trying to get [ __ ] done that has
reinforced how imperative it is from a
practical perspective it's one thing to
understand logically why anger is
counterproductive
yeah and it's it's quite another to not
just keep your anger in check but to
sort of sublimate it into a different
area that you can strengthen right and
I'm not the Paragon of this I still get
pissed off but there's a difference
between being angry and doing things out
of anger yeah totally yeah yeah you're
allowed to feel angry look I get pissed
off and yeah
not so much a question of suppressing
anger it's it's more of a question of I
think taking notice of what angers you
so that over time fewer things hopefully
anger you and one thing that's been very
helpful to me also and this is I can't
remember while I do remember one quote
from Krista Tippett who has a podcast
called on being which I believe I'm
gonna paraphrase it but that that anger
is fear shown publicly and so I try to
at least as an exercise if I'm really
angry to journal or sit and just think
about for a moment if this were
traceable to a fear what would the fear
be right so it's Reese opposing that
it's accurate for the sake of a thought
exercise sure and because anger at least
for me right anger is it's harder to
wrestle in the sense that like head-on
treating anger as an object it's harder
for me to to grapple with and to disarm
if that makes sense because I get I get
where we're at the story I tell myself
that perpetuates anger is well it's the
principle yeah justice must be served
yes this is death done I get on my raise
how dare they you know I could do this
yeah I get on my high my high horse of
righteousness and you can justify a lot
of stupid behavior that way and but I
don't quite know how to diffuse it
whereas if I can take the anger and turn
it into fear or not necessarily turn it
into fear but find a source that is
really do fear then I can use fear
setting or other exercises per minute
audio malorum etc to turn down the
volume
sure so that's that's a step that I
found very helpful also okay I'm curious
about fear because
obviously you have your fear setting
stuff which which you talk about in your
TED talk which which is probably very
timely for people right now but you know
having sort of two young kids you get
this sort of pit in your stomach right
and I can sort of empathy people are
really afraid right and I'd be curious
was there two things want to be curious
what you say to someone who is afraid
and then the other thing like oh maybe
am on a riff on I was kind of thinking I
was trying to think of so I was born in
87 so I was like what what scary things
did my parents go through with kids
which was actually really helpful so I
was like you know Black Monday there was
obviously 9/11 there's the the tech
bubble bursting there's the financial
crisis there's the end of the Cold War I
tried to go through and think there two
wars in in in the Gulf right like so so
that was something I did but I'm just
curious like how are you thinking about
fear and what would you say to someone
who who is being overwhelmed by fear
it's a very good question it's a very
timely question I don't I don't look I
don't have confidence in a single answer
for that okay in the sense that I do
think it's it's very highly dependent on
what you're afraid of and I have
relatives who had restaurant jobs and so
on and they're in very tough positions
and I don't I wouldn't want I wouldn't
want to make this purely an academic
exercise and lose sight of the fact that
fear is a gift in many cases it tells
you what is wrong so I don't want anyway
to seem like I'm detached from reality
by making it sort of mental gymnastics
exercise so let's start there
I would say that and I've been telling
myself this so I can uh-huh which is
just because you're feeling afraid I
have for instance I have older parents
in poor health who are in New York yeah
that causes has caused me quite a bit of
fear and anxiety and there's very little
I can do and there's very little I can
do and I can do a lot and I've very good
content
and I have very good contacts in New
York itself and to to an almost complete
extent there's next to nothing I can do
if they get sick yeah and that has
produced a sense of feeling helpless or
hopeless or in able to help that I'm
very unaccustomed to and so what I've
been telling myself and might be helpful
others is number one it's okay to feel
afraid like that doesn't make you flawed
that means that you're sort of
evolutionary machinery is intact and
there's a lot of value to that right
yeah yeah and so I would say that you're
not alone you're not flawed millions of
people tens of millions probably
hundreds of millions are feeling the
same thing right now and there are
reasons to be afraid it doesn't mean
there's not it does not mean there's
nothing you can do you always have
options right you always have options
that's the other thing I would say and
this is what I'm saying to myself so you
always have options you may just not
like those options right right sure
right so for instance if you look at the
plight of some workers right now who
have gone from kind of getting laid off
from one job to say delivering groceries
for fill in the blank app or company and
want more personal protective equipment
in order to do that job it's a very very
difficult situation to be in because
number one no matter how much those
companies would love to give you
personal protective equipment right now
health care workers don't even have
enough PPE personal protective equipment
so you have then you you might be
inclined in such a position to say I
have no choice you do have choices they
just may be very unattractive right so
yeah it could stop working for a period
of time you could move in with your
parents you could ask a friend for a
loan you could
sell some of the belongings you have
that you have great sentimental
attachment to or maybe your only car or
whatever it might be I'm not saying
these are all viable I'm just
brainstorming there fair or that they're
fair yeah you have to I mean for me I
just take fair out of the equation I
think I don't think fair except perhaps
under the law as equal treatment of
citizens
I don't think fair is very I don't think
it's an enabling concept right right you
know the Stokes would agree it's a you
know Epictetus egos it's not things that
upset us it's our judgment about things
and so fair is an opinion we have about
an objective reality that we're in right
so if I were trying to train a group of
a thousand people to be a really
effective like autonomous army but
benevolent army for handling like
weather not just weathering but
benefiting from the crisis mm-hmm I
think in and if they were just computers
like you know West world hosts that I
could program there's an operating
system there's certain concepts and
questions I would remove I think that
unfair is as true as it may be
subjectively or even objectively it is a
disabling word that even if you are a
victim puts you into the passenger seat
of life where you feel like you do not
have options nor take actions and that
is paralyzing and it's just going to
compound your fear so I would remove
that and then there are questions right
and I alluded to this a second ago and I
probably straying from the Stoics but I
feel like I've been so infused and if
you've heard of any of these large trees
in the Pacific Northwest that have like
30% salmon DNA from salmon being dropped
off bears and so on they become these
hybrids I feel that's maybe too long a
story to explain now but I believe
Radiolab has a good episode on on this
but the the wood wide web if you want to
look it up WOD but the point of that
extremely confusing sidebar is that I
feel like stoicism from having read it
and ingested it and ruminated on it and
reread it and so on over the years has
kind of infused my thinking yeah to a
very large extent so the the then there
are questions of and this definitely
harkens back to certainly some of the
moral letters to Lukey Lewis if we want
to cite some of the sources which by he
wrote in difficult times you know in
please you know at the end of his career
he was threatened by a tyrant like he
wasn't writing this in in a fun and
joyful vacation no no he wasn't and
that's that's Molly who's gonna Molly's
my dog is in the habit of going apeshit
these days Molly you feel stressed
because coronavirus I know she's
actually she's actually pretty stoked
ever humans home but I digress this is
this is audio/video Verret a quarantined
edition so I was going to say that if
you look at say one of Senecas letters
where he's composing this letter and
it's it's somewhat petulantly written
which I find hilarious
sure as are many of his letters but what
one of them he's writing as he's
discussing the I suppose you would call
it like a spa slash gym underneath him I
don't know if you remember where you can
you know this is this is lapping of
flesh and the grunting of lifting
weights and all this and it's I open
still miss that with that letter I love
that one yeah it's a great letter it's a
really really great letter so this may
not be the perfect citation but the
point I was going to make is that the
question I was asking myself early on
for me and my family and it's the
question you should be asking initially
was how do we how do we ensure we don't
die and physically financially how do I
ensure that my clan doesn't die and that
sounds traumatic I don't think
I don't think it's gonna seem that
dramatic I mean those are the stakes
those are the stakes or I mean they're
85 refrigerated double-wide trailers
that were just brought into New York
yesterday is temporary mortuaries right
I mean yeah this is real and I have
relatives in number of hotspots so these
these are these are steaks yeah now what
I'm trying to ask since I have checked
off at least for the time being the
lower rungs of Maslow's hierarchy of
needs
yeah not and not everyone is in a
position to do that nonetheless I do
think this question is really worth
asking and I owe my girlfriend credit
also for reinforcing this because she's
very good at this and that is how can
you make the next three to six months
some of the most enjoyable or productive
of your life or or if that's too much
pressure right you can phrase it
different ways you know how can you make
the next three to six months something
you look back upon as a sacred time that
you really treasure not just survive
right and just cut was kind of like and
look I'm not whatever I'll use it but I
heard a Nelson Mandela story once from
Tony Robbins actually who asked he asked
Nelson Mandela during his time in prison
how did you survive something along
those lines and he said he said oh I
wasn't surviving I was preparing and I
think that that type of question not how
I can survive how you can survive in a
sense is sort of like extreme frugality
and I've had my cup of coffee so I'm off
to the races but it's kind of like
extreme frugality in the sense that if
you're trying to find financial freedom
through one tool and that is extreme
frugality you have a finite ceiling to
that yeah right like you make let's just
call it for simplicity $1,000 I'm making
this up that was not a week and you can
cut from that
you may make some Faustian bargain and
about things that materially detract
from your quality of life but
nonetheless the most that you could
possibly subtract is $52,000 a year yeah
right is ignoring taxes and everything
whereas if you're building a business
you have or you have income generation
and you're also focused on that you have
a much broader scope of options sure and
similarly if you ask how can I survive
like survive is a binary pass fail yeah
and I feel like that places a ceiling on
the options that are visible to you if
that makes any sense yeah so when I ask
how could I most in and I'm going to use
a word here that might bother people but
if you were to ask how could I most
profit and benefit from the next three
to six months like what is this an
opportunity to do that I would never
otherwise do so I've been for instance
like getting rid of clothing that I've
had for years and cleaning up the garage
and doing this stuff that seems so
mundane but it will it would otherwise
not get done so I'm trying to ask myself
you know if this were a sacred time and
that what can I do or not do that will
lead me say we're out of this in a year
to some extent to look back and say wow
I'm so glad we had that time in a sense
because it allowed me ABC as opposed to
[ __ ] I didn't realize that was going to
be so valuable in so many ways and I was
blind to it at the time yeah the the
economy that I use that Robert Greene
gave me and I have this written around
somewhere I was going to show it to you
but he says a lifetime or dead time what
will it be
and I think that's like whether you're
whether this quarantine goes for two
more weeks obviously is going to go much
longer than that or whether it goes for
two more years all you know is that you
have that block of time what you do
control is how you use that time and
what you get out of it I have one one
thought on fear there's a Hebrew saying
that I love
it's from the 1800s but he goes the
world is a narrow bridge and the
important thing is to not be afraid the
point is when you're walking on a narrow
balance beam or a narrow bridge the one
thing you can't do is be scared because
it'll mess you up and you'll fall and I
think that's sort of the predicament
we're in it's not fair nobody chose it
it's not our fault
but you gotta cross this bridge now and
this fear fear as you said there has
some evolutionary reasons but courage is
going to be important right and that's
one of those sort of course stoic
virtues which is like and there's
another quote I love from Faulkner he
says you can be scared it's okay to be
scared you can't help that
she says but-but-but don't be afraid do
you know what I mean like I think you
have to you have to keep going that's
just the reality so you might as well
yeah if afraid is being paralyzed right
so for instance a few more comments on
fear yeah because you just reminded me
of a few things so and I this could be
apocryphal but I believe based on the
sources I had at the time I have no idea
what they are that this is true so Dean
Martin now that name may not mean much
to a lot of people but in his day Dean
Martin was the consummate entertainer
sort of top tier top five most
recognizable names in the United States
probably yeah and he used to vomit he
would get so nervous and one could say
afraid that he would vomit for every
performance Mike Tyson same story and
his hit the trainer who really made Mike
Tyson Mike Tyson cus D'Amato you can
find video or at least audio of custom
Otto's saying this he would say the hero
and the coward feel the same thing they
feel the fear
it's what the hero does that makes him
different and Tyson was also yes
terrified I mean terrified may not be
the right word but fearful before he got
into the ring one of the most dominant
boxers of all time sure and if they
can't get a
immunity bracelet for fear sure
unreasonable to expect yourself to and I
would also say if this is helpful to
anybody it's very specific to the United
States but the United States at this
point in time we're recording this April
first happy April Fool's Day and right
now New York is is the eBay of the US
the global who Bay effectively it's the
new global epicenter or will be this is
going to continue the United States is
going to be the largest hotspot unless
things change dramatically in Russia
it's probably going to be the largest
hot spot in the world for some time to
come and the prior to Pearl Harbor
well the strategic belief on the part of
the Japanese was that by destroying the
Pacific Fleet the morale and
capabilities of the US would be
completely sure shut down or paralyzed
for a period of time what instead
happened when you know the bear got
stabbed in the eye with a stick
meaning the US is that within a very
short period of time that would have
previously been inconceivable suddenly
we were producing more tanks than
civilians in all of Japan and that's an
exaggeration but the yeah cut the
capacity of the United States when it is
forced into a corner or feels as though
it's been forced into a corner through
extreme states of duress and crisis it's
not automatic are truly staggering right
and we've [ __ ] this up so many ways
it's it's really hard to overstate how
badly we've screwed this up in terms of
supply chain chain management and so on
but nonetheless I think give it six
months things are gonna look very very
different and yeah like it or not the
global economy is dependent on the US
enlargement yeah right so not that it's
too big not that it's too big to fail
every empire comes to its close but but
at this point in time it is in
everyone's best interest the United
States not collapse almost
everyone's best guess so right Russia
has gas to sell China has products to
export and so on and so forth right and
so so I I am I'm very confident that
crisis will overcome incompetence if
that makes any sense I'm very confident
that things will get worse yeah the
economy is going to get sort of kicked
in the nuts for a while this is not
going to be a 1/4 affair at all and the
u.s. is going to have to take very
extreme what might be seen as extreme
measures to have any chance of survival
economically speaking up so that gives
me a that gives me a degree of optimism
if that makes sense that that gives me a
degree of optimism maybe it will prove
unfounded I hope that's not the case yet
that also has the the example of Pearl
Harbor and it's not the perfect example
it's just a very easily grasped visual
example I think shows in there many
examples of this what the US can do in
times of crisis so I'm that gives me
some degree of of optimism as well so
I'm sure you've gotta go so as far as
this sort of a place to close because I
think this ties in well to the fear and
I think it ties well into stoicism what
I love about the Stoics in particularly
the Stoics and the Epicureans were
actually much closer philosophically
than people thought right and and you're
you you you love the good life you have
epicurean tendencies but what I what I
think what I think what I suspect draws
you to the Stoics and ultimately draws
me to the Stoics and I think why there
is this threat of Stoicism going not
just in the Roman Empire but to the
founding of America to the u.s. Civil
War to a lot of the great movements in
history is the Stoics felt that we were
obligated to participate in public life
to serve the common good to help other
people most of the greatest explained
not because of what they wrote but
because the actual heroism that they did
in their life and I mean Marcus really
specifically is the Emperor for fifteen
years of the Antonine plague you know he
doesn't flee Rome at one point famously
is one of my favorite stories in all of
history as as the Roman economy is
collapsing under the weight of this
pandemic
he he he forgives most of the debts
owned to the empire and then he goes
through the Imperial Palace and he marks
down the treasures owned by the Emperor
for sale on the palace lon
to to like sort of get the economy going
so this to me is what like I think this
goes to your point when when stuff
breaks down real leaders stand up and so
maybe as a place to close for people who
are afraid but want to put that energy
somewhere productive what do you advise
people as far as how can they help how
can they make a difference what and and
what good can individuals do you know
obviously there's a lot of we all have
different resources and skills but what
would you advise people to think about
as far as making a difference and and
using this as an opportunity to just to
do that sort of ultimate stoic duty yeah
thanks for the question that's a good
question I want it I want to just make
it an observation first and that is you
basically have the trifecta of books for
understanding and handling this entire
chapter in our history right behind your
head for those people who aren't
watching the video you have and I'll
read from the bottom up you've got the
Black Swan you have is it the 48 laws I
can't really have 48 laws 48 laws of
power and then mastery so the black swan
by and then and then I have meditations
right and know it and then meditation
yeah
see if but the black swan I perhaps just
as much so fooled by randomness by NN
Holub tal EB I think in porn extra anti
fragile but the Black Swan or fooled by
randomness
specifically I think help to explain
what we are contending with and why it
is so difficult for humans to grasp what
is happening and properly prepare for it
so I think that is that is worth reading
then if you want to understand how
seemingly confusingly and irrationally
different leaders are behaving and how
polarity is affecting our response to
this in the United States and elsewhere
not just here you look at Brazil it's
the same story then the 48 laws of power
do a great job of explaining that and
then if you take mastery and the 48 laws
of power combined those can act as a
possible road map for the abilities you
want to develop in this sacred pause
that is being provided to you not
inflicted upon you necessarily I
understand there are some very serious
costs but that's just a way that you
could plausibly or try to frame it if
you want to feel enabled not disabled
those are three fantastic books for the
for the quiver I'm just gonna say that
first
as far as stoic / civic duty and like
you said many of these Stoics per se if
we if we just if we just put aside the
best known names if we put aside Marcus
Aurelius we put aside Epictetus we put
aside Seneca and so on you still have
George Washington Thomas Jefferson these
people are not known as Stoics and yet
they they were very much informed and
directed by yeah much of stoic
philosophy and to the extent that George
Washington I guess at Valley Forge had
the troops perform I'm blanking on the
name of the play but it was a play about
it was Cato right mmm Cato to boost
morale and continue the fight and the I
want to make comment in response to
something you said and then I'll answer
said directly and that is that I do have
epicurean tendencies I find the at the
Epicureans to be of great interest but
what allows me
to tend the garden to drink my wine and
derive great pleasure from simple things
is the safety net that is stoicism yeah
for me I do not think as someone who may
be a story for another time but had some
very traumatic experiences in childhood
and have has always been hyper vigilant
without stoicism and tools that are
complementary to stoicism I don't feel
like I have the safety net underneath me
with which I can then walk across that
narrow bridge yeah and that that is what
allows the Epicureanism so it really is
the precursor and necessary antecedent
to those things as far as helping how
can you help there are two different
levels of answers the first would be my
my most common recommendation and that
is don't try to save the world help the
people around you yeah and think of if
you are fortunate enough to be in a
stable financial position even if you
are suffering financial hardship that
you have time think of how you could
reach out to people and offer your
support that support could be a weekly
zoom or Skype chat with a handful of
friends who are all sharing difficulties
it could be reaching out to your barber
I'm bald so I don't have barber but
reaching out to your barber or your
local coffee shop owner or
fill-in-the-blank someone to offer to
help in some fashion because you know
they're also suffering from financial
hardship that could be paying them some
amount of money if you have the
financial means a gift card and then
cash it's like buy 6 months of haircuts
in advance right it could be something
like that it could also be simply
reaching out to them and asking how can
I help and more often than not because
I've done this with say the dog walker
who I've used who's just fantastic and I
want them to survive this
the say house cleaners who helped with
my home I've reached out with these
offers and asked how can I help would
you like me to pay in advance
would you like to simply let me continue
paying most of them have declined but
the act of asking how can I help and
then possibly offering if you have the
means or the space is tremendously
I think reassuring in times of
uncertainty and the gift doesn't have to
be capital the support doesn't need to
be money it could just be group cohesion
and people feeling that they have a
safety net of sorts in your offer acting
locally in that sense makes I think it's
tremendously compelling if you try as I
have done for the last few weeks to
figure out how to save the world or
early on just how to stem the tide for
the United States to buy time there were
certain things that I could do say as it
related to South by Southwest and so on
but I am in a very unusual position and
I have a large platform yeah for others
to feel compelled to do something like
that is I think very unproductive
because it's going to be like shouting
into gale force winds it's it's gonna be
very frustrating and I don't think
terribly healthy for people to try so
act locally number one if you are
looking for outfits and ventures that
are focused on this crisis and you want
to contribute in some fashion there is
there is a GoFundMe campaign going on
right now depending on when this is
published which is a collaboration I'm
blanking on the exact organizations flex
port I know is one of them flex port
calm or flex port org for such donate
but they along with a number of
organizations have put together a large
GoFundMe campaign if you just search
flex port go flying
frontline responders funds yeah that's
right so frontline responders fund I
would say appears to be well vetted I've
had conversations with the sea
flex port and feel confident in their
integrity at this point I don't know
them that well but they certainly have
checked a lot of good boxes there's
another organization which may be part
of the same maybe not called operation
masks operation masks org is co-founded
by a number of people I've had some
contact with and that is this landscape
is very rapidly changing and access to
personal protective equipment and other
items is is in a state of constant flux
particularly since we have States
competing against one another and
driving prices up I mean the entire
thing is quite a [ __ ] spectacle of
messiness but I do think the you said
the frontline responder is fun this is
go fund me campaign which includes a
flex port and operation masks are two
that have kind of checked a few boxes
for me I can't vouch for either 100% but
there is a lot of noise and those are
two that seem to have cut through the
noise so those would be another two
options yeah it's going to say food
banks anything you can do to prove that
people from having to leave their houses
or go to the store is very important yep
so food banks I think are another
another good option for helping say
locally or helping where you grew up
yeah yeah or both so those would be a
few that come to mind and you know last
but not least I would say one way you
can help is commit to be constructive
and consider consider perhaps
experimenting and I'm considering doing
this myself because I think right now it
could be particularly valuable something
like the 21 day no complaint experiment
that yeah that will bow and vo w en
wrote about long ago in believe it was
this first book but this if you just
search 21 day no complaint experiment
it'll come right up yep I do feel like
complaining is easy it's in vogue it's
seductive it is reinforced socially and
it for me at least is
early counterproductive I think that
complaining and anger are similar in the
sense and I can't recall the attribution
for this but that the there's an
expression is it relates to anger that
you know a vessel that holds acid is
damaged more than anything it pours acid
upon and if you are the vessel for anger
or complaining I think it does more
damage to you than that which you point
it at and for that reason if you want to
improve or maintain or improve your
health your well-being and your ability
to function as a contributor in society
I think a no complaint experiment goes a
long way and by the way if you address
complaining which is easier to identify
and measure sometimes than anger there
is a very significant carryover effect
in to decreasing anger very very large
carryover effect so those would be a few
things that come to mind as as possible
actions people could take yeah and I
think for daily stoic we've been doing
this sort of a live-time deadtime
challenge like how are you going to use
this time I think that's the so it's
it's locally you know what can you do
for your family what can you do for your
neighbors you know if you have old
people that live near you what can you
get them so they don't have to leave
their house right like that but then I
think also you know this is now a time
for entrepreneurs and business people
like if everyone is sitting at home
watching Netflix for the next three
months that's going to be worse economic
damage from that then if people are at
home being productive thinking about you
know I mean like I think the there isn't
a real economic damage to to the world
grinding to a halt it's not just hey you
can't go to the pizza restaurant anymore
but it's like if you cease working and
you cease thinking and you cease taking
care of the people that you're supposed
to be taking care of there's gonna be
even longer lasting residue from this as
well yeah I agree I think
this is a you know an unfortunate and
special set of circumstances that can
really foster a sense of community where
community has largely broken down yes
right behind us where where we kissed as
David Brooks has said yeah and I mean I
I remember when I moved from San
Francisco to Austin and my first
neighbors approached me and like knocked
on my door and I feel like in a karate
stance because it was so shocking to me
since that never happened in San
Francisco and right I've had more
contact at a distance with sure my
neighborhood in the last few weeks than
in the last few years and I do think
there's there's something really unusual
about that that will disappear it will
or at least dissipate let me say that
it'll dissipate once business gets back
on track and we have up we have a very
unusual window of time in which as you
put it and I really like that expression
that you said this from Robert Greene
the alive time dead time yeah what could
you speak to just for my benefit since I
have it I don't remember reading about
this what what characterizes a lifetime
versus dead time or how does he talk
about it so-so actually came up when I
was thinking about leaving my job to
become a writer I had about a year left
that I owed American Apparel and so I
said Robert you know think about leaving
to become a writer what should I do and
he said this year for you could be a
lifetime or at that time you could show
up to work every day you know cash your
paycheck you know sit at your desk or
you could learn as much as possible you
can meet as many people as possible you
could the day you leave your job be have
all the research and preparation that
you need done for your book right so and
and so I actually ended up writing about
this and he goes the enemy but I tell
the story of Malcolm X Malcolm X goes to
prison is at this point is known as
Malcolm little he's sentenced to about
10 years he spends every day in that
prison cell reading writing studying he
basically
gives himself a college education in in
this prison and so I think you know
Nelson Mandela spent a far worse time in
prison than any of us are going to be
spending her in this quarantine
Shakespeare Isaac Newton they all spent
time in quarantine
you know fleeing the plague but how they
chose to use that time to write some of
their greatest works to develop
relationships to come up with theories
about the universe you know to study to
learn to get in touch with themselves
that's a lifetime yeah Isaac Newton had
one of the most productive years of his
entire life of course yeah and so I
think I think that's what's so beautiful
and haunting about history is like oh
this actually isn't new I was telling
you about that the statute this is
another thing I keep on my desk this is
a penknife
that's from I think that the the Year
200 ad kind of like this nice be
speaking of prison it looks like for
those people who are watching the video
it looks like a ship that you would make
out of a mattress coils but but you just
think about the amount of times that
human beings have spent doing exactly
what we're doing which is I can't go
outside a lot of Commerce and business
has ground to a halt this situation is
not new at all and the question is some
of those people use that time
productively Isaac Newton Shakespeare
and then far more people other people
were in the exact same quarantine as
William Shakespeare and they did not
write Macbeth you know and so that
that's that's the one you don't control
that you're in the situation the Stokes
would say but you do control how you
respond to the situation what you use it
for and I think that's ultimately what
that's that's what we should all be
focused on here here all right let's do
want to close it there yeah
it's closed there yeah appreciate it
yeah for sure and not just I mentioned
the fear setting for people who wanna
check check that out they can just go to
Tim dot blog /head it's also a talk but
the text can be quite helpful as a
supplement and you have to exercise
their right you should
yeah it's it's all there there's nothing
there's no paywall there's no there
shouldn't be any kind of block if
there's a pop-up you can just close it
but no I mean you actually show these
like it's more than just watching the
talk you like give people how to do the
exercise so that's what I tell them I
give them all the instructions and
examples in the in the text and since
this is something I use myself as well
awesome man really appreciate it yeah my
pleasure good to see you all right the
ekor to see you
you